the foods that most intrigued me are
ones which we currently don't have
access to I travel the world to find
indigenous foods that might be appealing
to the chef's very Vegas the chefs are
used to me proposing some odd ideas it
tastes like like the boss my name is
Brett Otto lanky and I own artisanal
foods we work with over 200 restaurants
on the strip all of the high-end venues
I saw Vegas is a desert and assumed that
they would need unusual ingredients
growing up I would hunt mushrooms in our
yard in Pennsylvania then when I was 13
I got the idea to start a small website
as during the whole combooo we would
sell fresh white truffles and all
truffle products my company brought two
of my passions together food and
business
we sell a lot of caviar foie gras Tzadik
meats the most odd foods we've had to
find duck tongues fork clatters about
the only one that stumped me I was never
able to find a legal fork ladder in the
United States when a new restaurant
opens a lot of them will actually
contact us and say hey you know we're
working on a new menu and we need some
inspirations week see what's new to here
that we can actually inspire them with
the ingredients that's a great success
black garlic has been very popular for
the last couple of years primarily used
in Korea then this one here is called
Condor e and cons er E comes from
northern Japan they take red peppers
which they grow they salt them with sea
salt and then lay them out on the snow
it's then pureed and fermented for a
total of three years I'll show you
something really special
this is Kopi Luwak coffee this is the
world's most expensive coffee it's
expensive because it's been digested
first by the civet cat which lives in
the jungles of Sumatra this is the
dropping from the civet cat the people
who make this coffee actually go into
the jungle and collect the droppings
they're then washed roasted then they
come here to the United States
this is Japanese a5 Wagyu or if you're
at a restaurant this steak would cost
200 to 250 with some products the higher
price will actually cause it to sell
more
these are freeze-dried sea cucumber it's
an animal that it lives on the bottom of
the ocean we can't sell these yet a bowl
of soup with sea cucumber could cost as
much as 250 dollars my whole mission has
always been to to introduce new foods to
the food system and have my small impact
on